hablamos de salud aquí en directo
américa de france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio marina a sardina marina
bienvenida muy buena mañana de luna
iniciamos una nueva semana hablando de
nuestra salud mental concretamente
marina en un nuevo estudio que cuestiona
el papel de la serotonina como la
causante de la depresión una enfermedad
que aumentó un 30% a nivel mundial
durante la pandemia de colitis y 9 hacia
raúl buenos días se trata de una
revisión de múltiples estudios
científicos realizada por la revista
molecular psychiatry en el que
proporciona una evidencia contundente
que desacreditaría el papel causal de la
serotonina como un factor en la
depresión en los últimos años se viene
hablando de la depresión como facto como
un desequilibrio químico en nuestro
cerebro sin embargo esto se está
cuestionando últimamente así como el
papel de los antidepresivos en su
tratamiento para hablar de ello nos
acompaña el doctor carlos pérez él es
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia buenos días doctor
cuéntanos expliquen qué es la serotonina
y cómo funciona en nuestro cerebro
recordemos que el cerebro es un conjunto
de células que se comunican de varias
formas una eléctrica y otra química la
forma química son los neurotransmisores
que dan señales como su nombre indica
químicas a través de componentes para
generar en comunicación entre las
neuronas la serotonina hace parte de sus
neurotransmisores y que se ha
involucrado en varios fenómenos
fisiológicos del cerebro dentro de ellos
sería atribuible a que su depresión es
decir la ausencia o la disminución
podría estar relacionado con la
depresión que es el limón es lo que nos
convoca esta mañana doctora muy buen día
feliz el lunes para usted le pregunto
entonces como cuestiones de trabajo de
la revista molecular psychiatry la falta
o los niveles bajos de serotonina como
la explicación de una enfermedad tan
compleja como lo es la depresión
lo primero que cuestión es la
complejidad que no es simplemente una
alteración química o ni balance químico
la causa de depresión este es un estudio
que revisa la evidencia de varias
decenas de estudios clínicos excluye
algo muy fundamental que es la
enfermedad bipolar que es una de las
limitaciones de este estudio y muestra
que en estas personas que padecen la
enfermedad no se ha encontrado evidencia
suficiente que sea consistente que sea
sólo la disminución de tener la causante
de la depresión eso no querer que no sea
importante tener en cuenta ese mecanismo
pero que no es tan simple como solamente
un hallazgo químico y nos abre la
alternativa de que hay otros fenómenos
sociales psicosociales que pueden estar
afectando y otros mecanismos que no
conocemos como causantes de esta
enfermedad que recordemos la depresión
es diferente de la tristeza la de la
tristeza la sentimos todos la depresión
en unos criterios que los médicos
evaluamos para poder diagnosticar
si la serotonina es uno de tantos
neurotransmisores que tiene nuestro
cerebro y está asociado a la depresión
este estudio lo pone en duda qué riesgos
hay de de poner esta duda sobre la mesa
y qué otros factores actúan para que una
persona padezca o no depresión
no es la psiquiatría ha sido consistente
que la depresión no se puede manejar
solamente como un aspecto químico y él
llama la atención que hacen los autores
a que la evidencia no es consistente y
que se sigan explorando caminos para
mirar cuáles son los desarrollos y que
definitivamente la depresión no
solamente es tomar tabletas sino
acompañarse de un profesional en salud
mental la psiquiatría la psicología y
las ciencias que estudian las ciencias
del comportamiento son las personas que
direccionan el tratamiento y lo
acompañan no es solamente ir a una
farmacia o automedicarse buscar en las
redes sociales cuáles son medicamentos
para la depresión y tomarlos porque
primero la depresión se sobre
diagnóstica y segundo el tratamiento y
el diagnóstico lo que tiene que hacer un
profesional de salud y no solamente
tratarlo con una tableta bueno hablando
precisamente de estos medicamentos de
autores era llegar al prozac aprobado
por muy grande por primera vez en
1987 la depresión es tratada con
medicamentos le digo entonces cómo
funcionan estos fármacos antidepresivos
y lo que este estudio nos muestra es que
se tiene que replantear cómo funcionan
estos medicamentos porque si se ha visto
que los medicamentos depresivos en
cierto tipo de pacientes son efectivos y
mejoran se atribuía que era un proceso
de recaptación de aumentar los niveles
de serotonina su mayor explicación pero
deben ser otros
mecanismos los que están involucrados en
que algunos de estos medicamentos bien
medicados por una proyección de salud si
son efectivos entonces no se está
negando su actividad lo que sí se está
cuestión es que sea simplemente la
relacionamiento con la célula también ha
sido todo viene una sociedad donde
millones de personas dependen
precisamente de estos fármacos para
tratar la depresión en recientemente en
los últimos en el último años un 6 por
ciento más de población está tratando la
depresión con fármacos antidepresivos
qué riesgos tiene esto y si hay una
adicción también a estos fármacos y en
este negocio tan millonario de las
farmacéuticas con los fármacos
antidepresivos
yo creo que la reacción que ha generado
este tipo de artículos ha sido muy
sensata en llamando la atención primero
que no es solamente un hallazgo químico
y por eso no es solamente los fármacos
los que tratan la depresión no según de
la importancia de la salud mental de los
psiquiatras la psicología y todas las
ciencias que estudia el comportamiento
para ayudar el tratamiento pero también
llama la atención sobre el
sobrediagnóstico confunde moss tristeza
con depresión reacciones de ajuste con
depresión y hay fenómenos de precios que
son orgánicos por un daño estructural en
el cerebro o por fenómenos genéticos
como trastornos de la personalidad o
enfermedad no enferma bipolar que no
están incluidos en este en estos
estudios que es la conclusión que
tenemos que primero no solamente son
fármacos y una depresión es un
diagnóstico médico no de redes sociales
no solamente leyendo el computador y
sobre diagnosticar lleva sobre tratar
entonces es un gran interesante estudio
que nos llama la sensatez en la salud
mental y a buscar ayuda en los
profesionales que ellos son los que
deciden cuál es el mejor tratamiento
doctor como siempre muchísimas gracias
por toda la información también gracias
marina por acompañarnos los despido para
saludar entonces a nuestro segundo
invitado del día
[Música]